so i want to follow up with you today on
april 1st the first day of april new
month um about what's going on with
radical republican trump is congressman
matt gates matt gates recently appeared
on the tucker carlson show
and announced that he is vindicated and
i was thinking vindic what are you
talking about vindicated you're under a
very serious investigation
in which you may be charged now there
are some who have already sort of moved
on and are assuming that because matt
gates hasn't already been charged he's
not going to be charged and remember the
the
possible crimes and charges have a large
range up to it including child sex
trafficking sex trafficking of a minor
sex trafficking of a minor across state
lines but needless to say for some
reason uh he thinks that he's been um
vindicated and uh here he is talking to
tucker carlson about it a year ago today
365 days that the justice department
leaked a story to the new york times
that it caught our attention immediately
they told the times they were
investigating congressman matt gates
republican of florida
for a very serious crime under aged sex
trafficking right
so gates made an appearance on this show
which turned out to be one of the
weirdest interviews we've ever done he
tried it true he has not been on fox
news since that day
but we did notice since we've been sort
of following it matt gates was never
charged with anything
so how is that the just department calls
new york times and says you're a sex
criminal and then a year later you're
not charged with anything so we thought
it'd be worth inviting congressman matt
gates back on the show
and here he is thank you so much for
coming on
so
you
were described in the new york times by
the justice department as a felony sex
criminal have you been charged do you
expect to be charged for felony sex
crimes no this was an operation to
destroy me to harm my family to hinder
my ability to serve the district and the
movement that i represent in congress
and we all know there's a pipeline of
leaks and lies that flow from the
justice department to the mainstream
media the new york times in particular
and that's not even a partisan criticism
of the biden administration that
happened during the trump administration
as well we saw it during the russia hoax
but the most important update the most
important thing that's happened since
our last honorary discussion
someone has been indicted and has pled
guilty to trying to shake down my family
based on this pile of lies and so i'm
not going to allow it to hinder me i'm
going to continue the important work
that i do here in the congress for my
constituents yeah so i'm not going to
ask any questions about your personal
life because it's not my business it's
really simple if you've committed a
crime let them charge you and they
haven't and they've smeared your name
again
your private life's your business
whether you committed a crime or not is
everybody's business and you have it and
there's one ask you one more time
crisply and clearly do you expect to be
charged for the crimes
of which they've accused you
no that would be a travesty i'm innocent
i have maintained my innocence i have
been entirely consistent on this fact
and each and every day the lies about me
unravel and are debunked and the things
i've said and admittedly it's pretty
wild to come on your show and say that
my family's being shaken down for 25
million dollars by some fraudsters some
with connections to the intelligence
community and the department of justice
but in fact someone has pled guilty to
just that so i feel vindicated each and
every day so he's vindicated now notice
a lot of the things that aren't said
there um tucker didn't ask have you been
cleared because the answer is he hasn't
been cleared that's number one it's also
important to mention
none of the claims reported about gates
have been debunked at this point in time
he's just not been charged yet he may
not be charged i'm completely open to
that possibility but tucker didn't ask
have you been cleared because the answer
is no
um
the the thing that he was accused of
doing
uh at one point he claimed he didn't
even know the woman in question we now
have a paper trail where we know that
venmo was actually used to get money
through an intermediary to the woman he
claimed never to have met so that has
not been debunked in fact that's been
confirmed uh and um none of the actual
claims to date have actually been shown
to be untrue
also remember just as like a reminder
about the weirdness of this story
in that weird interview um a year ago i
remember i was on vacation when this
broke and i was on my phone going what
the hell is matt gates talking about
matt gates appeared with tucker in that
weirdest interview we've ever done
and he almost like implicated tucker by
saying you were there with me and had
dinner with one of the people i was with
this was one of the strangest moments
i've ever seen again i only know what
i've read in the new york times i can
say that actually you and i went to
dinner about two years ago your wife was
there and i brought a friend of mine
you'll remember her and she was actually
threatened by the fbi told that if she
wouldn't cop to the fact that somehow i
was involved in some pay for play scheme
uh that she could face trouble and so i
do believe that there are people at the
department of justice who are trying to
smear me uh you know providing for
flights uh and hotel rooms for people
that you're dating who are of legal age
is not a crime
and i'm just troubled that the lack of
any sort of legitimate
investigation into me would then permute
would then convert into this extortion
attempt
i i don't remember the woman you're
speaking over the context at all
honestly but
if anything could accurately be
described as kafka-esque i think it
would be that so listen yes the truth is
gates has not been charged
um but he has not been cleared
and the assertions gates has made
many of those have been proven to be
false like i don't know this woman
actually you do and you did send her
money supposedly for tuition and books
but you did send her money
and uh the investigation is ongoing but
what a what a bizarre situation
one of our sponsors is atlas vpn an
awesome company offering free vpn
subscriptions to journalists in ukraine
risking their safety to do really
important work but atlas vpn also has a
lot to offer all of my viewers your
internet traffic can be observed by a
number of parties your isp big tech
platforms even the government that's why
i use atlas vpn whenever i connect to
the internet i don't want to be spied on
i don't want companies selling my
personal information you shouldn't
either atlas vpn protects your internet
connection by hiding your ip address
making you invisible online with just
one atlas vpn account i can protect all
of my devices at the same time you just
turn it on once forget about it and stay
protected and their speeds are great
i've never had any lag while streaming
video content with atlas vpn atlas vpn
is giving my audience 82 off this comes
out to just 199 a month plus you get one
month free just click the link below and
use the code pacman